The tools belong to the Cook Islanders.
Tātatau was current in the islands
it’s just that colonialism had wiped it out.
There’s not anyone else here doing the traditional form.
The revival here started out from tattoo machines.
The machine is not connected to the old ways
so I think that gap is vast for an outsider to stand up
in that gap and hold the tools up.
It can be challenging.
I have a lung condition, it’s something that I’m born with,
it’s not something I contracted and
it’s also something that you can’t catch.
Cystic fibrosis is the name.
For me it’s personally been a helping hand,
it’s been something that’s...
I felt like made me engage in life.
What makes Moko a good student,
he carries the tools well,
he takes the responsibility really seriously.
I think the importance of teaching and
having an apprentice and what we do is something
that has been done for a really long time.
That act of now sharing that with Moko confirms that.
The responsibility with the tools is an important one
because the tools, the designs, they don't belong to me
and it’s something that’s been passed down.
So it’s my responsibility to ensure that they are in safe hands.
It’s like being a caretaker, a caretaker of everything,
it’s like using it with love and passion and respect.